حمية البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​التي تتكون من
مجموعة غنية من الفواكه والمكسرات والأسماك
والحبوب الكاملة والخضروات معروفة
بفوائدها المتمثلة في تقوية العظام
والعمر الأطول والوقاية من أمراض القلب
وبعض السرطانات الآن مرتبطة بانخفاض
خطر الإصابة بواحد من أسوأ أنواع الثدي.
سرطان الثدي مستقبلات هرمون الاستروجين السلبي
سرطان الثدي هو شكل من أشكال المرض بعد انقطاع الطمث
وفقا لدراسة جديدة
أجريت في هولندا
وظهرت في المجلة
الدولية للسرطان وجد الباحثون أن
ظهور سرطان الثدي السلبي
كان أقل بنسبة 40 في المائة إذا كانت النساء
تتراوح أعمارهن بين 55 و 55 سنة.  69 ملتزمًا بشكل وثيق
بالنظام الغذائي المتوسطي ER
سرطان الثدي لديه تشخيص سيئ ومن المعروف
أنه أكثر عدوانية ولديه مخاطر أعلى
للتكرار ، كما أن
خيارات العلاج أقل من 250.000 امرأة يتم
تشخيصها سنويًا في الولايات المتحدة مع سرطان الثدي.
سلطت النتائج الضوء على تأثير
الأنماط الغذائية على خطر الإصابة بالسرطان ، لذا
يمكن الوقاية منه  مخاطر الحبوب تعني المزيد من الفواكه
والخضروات وقليلًا من اللحوم الحمراء والحلويات
في دقيقة الصحة اليوم أنا كيم
أوتشرسون